ah
bienvenidos al debate de france 24 soy
santiago lópez gonzález en eeuu hay
opiniones divididas tras el pedido del
presidente job aiden de hacer
obligatoria la vacunación contra el cob
y 19 en las empresas de más de 100
empleados también entre los empleados
federales y los militares muchos
sectores ven esta imposición como una
violación a sus derechos ya las
libertades civiles en francia por
ejemplo la exigencia de la vacunación
para los empleados del sector salud ya
entró en vigor desde el 15 de septiembre
y provocó toda una serie de
manifestaciones ciudadanas cerca de 3000
empleados del sector de salud en ese
país europeo ya fueron suspendidos de
sus cargos por no haber sido inoculados
italia también está dando el debate en
altas instancias del gobierno será
entonces éste el primer país democrático
que podría exigir una vacunación
totalmente obligatoria para todos los
segmentos de la población incluso en
américa latina' también algunos
gobiernos están buscando imponer la
obligatoriedad
en algunos sectores de la sociedad por
ejemplo en río de janeiro ya están
pidiendo el pasaporte sanitario para
ingresar a algunos sitios públicos pero
eso es particularmente en esa ciudad
brasileña lo cierto es que son debates
que los gobiernos democráticos hacen con
pinzas no hay popularidad en los
gobiernos para empezar a tomar esta
serie de medidas después de los dos años
que hemos tenido las medidas que han
tenido que tomar a nivel económico y
social para hacer frente a la pandemia
de kobe 19 pero la inmunidad de grupo no
se ha podido conseguir el coronavirus
sigue presente y siguen aumentando los
casos y los defensores de los derechos
humanos y también de las libertades se
sienten atacados con este tipo de
medidas hoy en el debate de france 24
vacunarse contra el kobe 19 obligatorio
si o no para analizar y conversar sobre
este tema hemos invitado a la doctora
roxana trejo ella es médica cirujana
también es magíster en salud pública se
encuentra en la ciudad de méxico también
está con nosotros el doctor carlos
castillo salgado él es médico
epidemiólogo es docente de epidemiología
del departamento de salud de la
universidad johns hopkins y aquí en el
estudio de france 24 hago esta
introducción rápida está con nosotros el
doctor carlos torres el es infectólogo
también es pediatra docente de la
universidad del bosque que está ubicada
en la ciudad de bogotá es profesor
visitante del instituto de child of
health creo que los dije ya completos
todos ustedes también nuestros
televidentes pueden participar en este
debate con sus comentarios y preguntas
pueden dejarlas en instagram en facebook
y también en twitter estamos como arroba
el debate efe 24 guión bajo s arroba
sant y luego es mi cuenta personal les
recuerdo que en este momento el
departamento internet me recuerda que
hay una encuesta en línea para que
ustedes dejen allí sus opiniones la
pregunta va relacionada con el caso de
francia que hizo ya efectiva la
obligatoriedad de la vacunación contra
el cob y 19 para el sector salud a
riesgo de suspensión laboral dejen así
pues sus comentarios y sus opiniones en
torno a este tema comenzamos entonces de
inmediato con él con el tema ya les
presenté a los invitados y comienzo
entonces pregunta roxana en la ciudad de
mexico la pregunta obligada para abrir
el debate vacunación obligatoria si o no
hola santiago un gusto gracias por
limitación pues fíjate que en el
contexto que vivimos en la pandemia yo
te diría sí aunque por supuesto existen
grupos en donde dirían no pero nosotros
que hemos vivido tan cercana en los
riesgos que se corren así como las
hospitalizaciones y el impacto a la
población pues creo que deberíamos de no
tanto instaurar la obligatoriedad sola
sino también creo la sensibilización
debe de ser muy importante todos estos
resultados que tenemos de personas que
no se quieren vacunar tiene que ver
también con esta mala información en
cuestiones digitales en donde las
personas pueden creer que es un riesgo
vacunarse yo diría así pero por supuesto
con un pues con una difusión muy grande
en relación a los beneficios de
vacunarse en la opinión de roxana de la
ciudad de méxico- roxana también es
socia fundadora y directivo de la
asociación latinoamericana de control de
infecciones complemento sus datos sobre
su formación le pregunto ahora al doctor
que nos acompaña acá en el estudio del
doctor torres aquí en la ciudad de
bogotá vacunación si o no santiago
gracias no hay una sola respuesta porque
por eso es la distrito que estamos
avocados pero coincido con que hay
grupos personal de salud personal de
primera línea el que está atendiendo a
personas mayores a personas de más alto
riesgo en que definitivamente debe
haberla también incluyo profesores que
están exponer exponica expuestos al tema
de la educación por supuesto que es
responsabilidad de los estados el tratar
de convencer a sus ciudadanos de una
manera adecuada y transparente sobre los
beneficios de la vacunación pero debemos
reconocer que no podemos meter en un
solo saco al que no se quiere vacunar el
que está el que genuinamente tiene una
edad duras de su salud propiamente sobre
la vacuna y está aquel que es producto
de la misma información de la
información maliciosa en la cual hay una
actividad realmente criminal la está
afectando a la población y que hace que
esta pandemia y la circulación viral
persista y por eso es que el no estar
vacunados de una manera profusa puede
hacer o es uno de los componentes más
importantes para que la pandemia
persista o sea
es individuales versus proliferación de
la pandemia con las complicaciones
económicas de salud que esto tiene
discusión grande dyn genera grandes si
estoy de acuerdo con la obligatoria
vamos por todos y por la obligatoriedad
hablo ahora con el doctor castillo en
eeuu doctor castillo bienvenido su
opinión para cerrar esta primera ronda
obligatoriedad si o no
como los dos
participantes también han indicado
tenemos que considerar que en general
así nuestro interés es
apoyar para el control de esta pandemia
y toda la evidencia indica que es muy
importante que la población está
vacunada nosotros en hopkins es un
requisito fundamental todo el personal
de salud incluyendo médicos enfermeras y
especialistas de todo tipo es uno de los
hospitales más importantes del mundo que
es obligatorio contener que todo el
esquema de vacunación
asimismo en las escuelas también
recordar que el 60% de la población en
las encuestas nacionales han indicado
que están de acuerdo con la
administración bailén de hacer
obligatoria
a la vacunación
interesantes puntos de vista continúa
aquí en el estudio con el doctor torres
y retomo algo de lo que usted dijo
doctor y es la desinformación la
información criminal la información no
verificada que está en las redes
sociales pero también el manejo que le
han dado algunos gobiernos en la región
de américa latina al manejo de la
información
algunos no proporcionaron datos exactos
sobre las vacunas o sobre cómo era el
manejo de la de la pandemia ni de las
medidas que iban a tomar y eso generó un
poco de susto por parte de la población
eso puede estar generando y trayendo
consecuencias a esta altura de la
pandemia para que muchas personas
decidan no vacunarse yo estoy de acuerdo
que hay una dinámica en el mundo entero
de la cual no está exenta latinoamérica
en el que existe una desconfianza hacia
los gobiernos y por supuesto eso se
ejemplifica bien también en los eeuu en
europa
pero por supuesto esta desconfianza raya
a veces en el tema político y en otros
intereses evidentemente y si bien puede
que algunos gobiernos no hayan sido
transparentes en esta información
en este instante que las vacunas
funcionan son altísimamente efectivas
disminuyen la mortalidad disminuyen las
ocupaciones hospitalarias pero por
supuesto no nos enfrentamos a un virus
oa un enemigo menos que formidable
entonces hay variantes que en gran parte
están desarrolladas por la presión que
da el no estar vacunado todo el mundo o
sea no olvidar que un factor muy grande
para la aparición de nuevas variantes es
el evento de no estar vacunados de una
manera completa gran franja de la
población de forma final para no quitar
más tiempo que el no vacunarse afecta a
esa parte y entonces evidentemente si
bien la información debe ser muy
transparente también debe quedar claro
que es esa transparencia tiene que
mostrar una clara disposición a vacunar
a todo el mundo de una manera rápida de
una manera equitativa de una manera
constante y asegurarnos que esos
recursos existan para lograr la
vacunación porque si no se vuelve este
círculo vicioso que no vamos a salir
nunca alcanzaron inmunidad de grupo si
no se alcanza una alta tasa de
vacunación total
roxana en la ciudad de mexico la sacó un
poco de su área médica para preguntarle
por un área de las que ya estábamos
mencionando y es violación de derechos
libertades la toma de decisión que los
ciudadanos tenga la capacidad de decidir
entre me voy a vacunar o no y la
responsabilidad que también hay como
ciudadanos y con nuestro colectivo con
nuestro entorno vacunar nos beneficia a
las comunidades donde nosotros estamos
ese balance es muy difícil lograrlo como
lo ve usted se están violando derechos
se le está obligando a la población a
inocularse contra el kobe 19 y se está
quitando y cortando esa capacidad de
decisión del ciudadano
bueno miren en méxico específicamente el
médico y ciudad de mexico para entrenar
en méxico aunque la ley general de salud
en el artículo 408 si refiere que en
instancias como pandemias la secretaria
no puede tomar la decisión de esta
obligatoriedad y hacer que las personas
se vacunen no lo ha hecho hasta hoy ha
sido una decisión individual de acudir
pero te quiero decir que al menos en mi
país hay estados que varía hay estados
donde las personas no se quieren vacunar
y hay estados del país donde las
personas se forman y duran 5 horas para
que puedan vacunarse social si existe
una diferenciación importante y esto
depende de los estados pero creo que un
punto que acaba de decir este es el tema
de que en la info de miami creo que el
atraso en dar esta respuesta y estas
aclaraciones a esta info dem ya que
producía que las personas algunas de
ellas no se vacunará no fortalece al
grupo no va a acumular escalones en
méxico no están muy fortalecidos por
esta individualidad ha sumado a otros
cuando se comunica de voz en voz y
disminuye pues el apego a la vacunación
este si existe en la ley general salud
en méxico poderlo hacer lo ocurrido
hasta hoy pero creo que instancias como
esto bailén en donde hay empresas que
existen personas que no se quieren
vacunar y que exactamente no sabe ni
dónde colocarlas en francia con esta
indicación de los profesionales salud
que están muy expuestos y que por
supuesto también sus compañeros van a
seguir expuestos mientras ellos no
cubran esta vacunación creo que son
instancias hay que tomarlas creo que
cada uno laboralmente tiene una
responsabilidad no solamente individual
sino también familiar y comunitaria y
por supuesto laboral y si esto está
dando como resultado un informe bien que
las personas no se vacunen creo que si
hay que hacer obligatoriedad pero
siempre de la mano de la sensibilización
o sea este infodema que pues ya llevamos
meses en ella y que hoy queremos hacer
las cosas para que no ocurra y que a lo
mejor nos ganó pues no hay que dejarla
fuera hay que tratar de dar esta
información tan certera que desde que
éramos pequeños nos llevaban los papás a
vacunar lo que pasa es que los adultos
cuestionamos mucho este tema de
vacunación no nosotros nos preguntaban
cómo éramos pequeños puede ser el médico
pediatra no sea no hay una no hay una
pregunta a vacunar te te llevabas porque
sabíamos que con eso muchos de los que
estamos aquí si no fuera por la
vacunación no estaríamos aquí eso lo
tienen que entender esa población que
hoy no se quiere vacunar si esa decisión
de su familia no hubiera sido vamos a
protegerte no estaríamos muchos
platicando entonces creo yo que al menos
en mi país no existe obligatoriedad pero
si la ley lo pudiera hacer hoy lo que se
ha hecho en méxico
plataformas de sensibilización se
colocan en todas las dudas que tiene la
población y que van de voz en voz
tratando después de dar la mejor
información e incentivar que las
personas se vacunen claro interesante
punto de vista a roxana si en la ciudad
de mexico doctor del castillo paso a
preguntarle por el caso de eeuu que es
donde usted se encuentra y que podemos
hacer una comparación con la sociedad
latinoamericana y con la sociedad de
eeuu vemos que la tasa de vacunación en
eeuu ha venido bajando en las últimas
semanas y en américa latina ha ido
subiendo lentamente en las medidas pues
que ha podido cada país hacer frente a
la pandemia ya la obtención de los dotes
de las vacunas pero hay un factor aquí
importante y es la disciplina ciudadana
la disciplina de los norteamericanos que
uno pensaría que es una sociedad de
primer mundo donde tienen todas las
condiciones
del sistema hospitalario eeuu que puede
tener sus críticas pero tienen las
vacunas disponibles y vemos a los
latinoamericanos que nos tocó esperar
muchas semanas para podernos vacunar y
entra en juego la disciplina de los
ciudadanos los estadounidenses no se
están vacunando
bueno en realidad
y se ha politizado muchísimo en el
proceso de vacunación y tenemos que ver
el proceso del año anterior y los
orígenes
e incluso en américa latina' yo hago el
monitoreo en 20 países con 80 de themis
egresados
y vemos que en realidad existió un
impacto de lo que se llama el impacto
trump en américa latina y en estados
unidos entonces se ha politizado y el
grupo que rechaza la vacunación
básicamente tiene una estructura
política porque obviamente
no ha demostrado desde el punto de vista
científico que los argumentos que están
utilizando con el no uso de la
vacunación que están en realidad muchos
de ellos inventando o creando
estructuras artificiales para indicar
que la vacuna no es segura sabemos qué
he estado este día verificando que la
mayoría de las unidades de cuidados
intensivos y los que están en
respiratorios del 99% son a individuos
no vacunados y esto no bajan demanda que
en muchos lugares se esté generando el
mandato para la vacunación hay que
recordar que en eeuu no es un el país en
donde la salud se estructura a nivel
federal sino a nivel estatal y lo que
está pasando es que las legislaturas
están negando esa oportunidad
particularmente en 17 estados para que
el personal de salud y los líderes
locales puedan generar
la obligatoriedad en la vacunación
aunque vemos que en la práctica la
mayoría de los negocios en muchos
hospitales
restoranes y requieren y la nueva
contratación
básicamente exige que estén vacunados
como lo los sigue la estructura de salud
15 de muchos hospitales en el país y el
mayor ejemplo de esta politización en
eeuu es este referendo al que fue
sometido el gobernador del estado de
california precisamente por las medidas
que tomó para hacer frente a la pandemia
kobe 19 siendo california uno de los
estados más afectados de la unión
americana en cuanto a casos a fallecidos
y a personas hospitalizadas hago la
ronda a la inversa sigo con la doctora
trejo para preguntarle usted mencionaba
brevemente los casos de francia el de
eeuu vemos que italia ya va a imponer
este pasaporte para todas las instancias
de la vida pública hagamos un balance
porque usted mencionaba que y si a la
vacunación en diferentes sectores de la
sociedad aquí vemos que eeuu le imponen
las empresas grandes y francia lo impone
o impone la vacunación para el sector de
la salud que es la persona las personas
que están en la primera línea de frente
contra el kobe 19
como entender que eeuu no haga lo mismo
con el personal de salud y prefiera
vacunar a los empleados antes que a los
funcionarios de salud roxana pues esta
es una pregunta bastante complicada de
qué es lo que exactamente pasa por la
cabeza del presidente bailén pero creo
yo que tiene que ver mucho también con
el impulso en la economía que ha sido
pues bastante dañada con la pandemia y
que ha impactado no solamente en la
macroeconomía sino también la
microeconomía y por supuesto las
empresas que sus trabajadores teniendo
un sistema de salud al menos en
vacunación en eeuu tan fuerte pues que
no tomen esa decisión de vacunarse creo
que eso al final impacta también en esa
empresa creo yo esto sí se debería
llevar también a los profesionales salud
pero por supuesto a mí imagino que nos
da de cobertura en profesionales es
mucho mayor que lo mejor en otros países
en el mismo en nuestro mismo país de
méxico aunque son el grupo más
sensibilizado por supuesto siempre
existen algunas personas que deciden por
alguna razón no vacunarse creo yo que si
debería de hacerse más una instancia
homogénea para poder impactar en la
actividad económica en la protección
individual y para poder evitar los daños
que están surgiendo pues a las familias
pero por supuesto con mayor impacto pues
a los países en la baja de la movilidad
y en la baja ve pues en la disminución
de estas inversiones económicas que
existe el arroyo que la decisión
seguramente fue con datos duros pero al
final en cada país se podría tomar su
decisión propia en base a su información
y con esto impactar en pues vacunarse
importante reflexión allí doctora a tres
goles por este lado que en el estudio
france24 doctor torres su opinión en
torno a este orden de ideas que venimos
desarrollando que el sector de la
sociedad debe ser obligatorio en este
caso vacunar como lo dice la doctora
depende de muchos factores pero vemos
los dos casos muy distintos francia ya
lo he mencionado a los personal las
personas del sector salud y eeuu a los
trabajadores e italia que acaba de decir
hoy acaba decidió hace unos pocos
minutos a todos los empleados de
públicas o privadas que no es que no
quiera vacunarse trabaja en la casa el
que vaya ya se tiene que vacunar si bien
digamos que nuestros países hay varias
consideraciones
digamos el caso de los eeuu es aplicable
en buena parte de nuestros países porque
éste infoem ya también afecta estos
grupos antivacunas bien sabemos que son
verdaderos conglomerados noticiosos si
estamos en un conglomerado de noticias
ellos lo son de cada diez libros de
vacunas que se venden por amazon.com 8
son anti vacunas y sólo dos son los que
de verdad están diciendo la información
científica
es un grupo que como dice peter holt es
de houston
claramente nuestro mensaje es nuestro de
ser considerado como una botella en un
mar de desinformación o sea lo que
hacemos los médicos y esas conferencias
gigantes grandísimas que todos los días
hacemos es una botellita con un mensaje
chiquito en un mar de desinformación
esto hay que entenderlo porque nuestros
países mucha gente cree que los que nos
están vacunando es que son un poco
ignorantes que no han entendido el tema
y por el contrario es una verdadera
cáncer que va por debajo afectando a
muchas áreas de la sociedad pero por
supuesto también hay que entender que
por lo menos en colombia en república
dominicana en perú sin duda en médico
hay una fracción de la población rural
en el que no se vacuna nadie usted ha
leído casos aquí en colombia que han
llegó a un pueblo y nadie se vacunó si
el cura pudo haber influido el pastor
religioso de esta religión o simplemente
la ignorancia el miedo la ausencia de
estar c&a y por supuesto aplicar vóley
que está obligatoriedad es como
victimizada la víctima o sea tenemos que
ir a hablar a enseñar a educar y la
gente lo va a hacer creo que eso es
claro y los otros son aquellos que
tienen esos componentes a veces de
revisiones que dicen que las vacunas
están hechas con embriones de abortos y
todo eso en que también la educación
vale la pena seguirle insistiendo pero
por supuesto cuando yo ya estoy hablando
de una persona que le pone una franja
afrenta al sistema que lo desafía que se
ríe del mismo que no se pone el
tapabocas que asalta verbalmente al que
no se lo paga que se lo ata pone que
hace que haya una manifestación en
manifestación en las afueras del colegio
para hacer que los niños tengan
tapabocas lo más absurdo que uno pueda
vivir en este mundo entonces cuando es
así esto si es un grupo son grupos muy
organizados que afectan claramente a los
demás entonces el ser un mandato una
obligatoriedad sin ninguna duda para las
personas que estamos en primera línea
para las personas que atienden público
es que estoy seguro que a ti no te
gustaría que haciendo todo el esfuerzo
de vacunación el del banco el de la
oficina de arquitectos el doctor o los
profesores no estuvieran vacunados con
contadas excepciones basadas en datos
médicos así que en general todas estas
normas que se supone están privando a
las personas de sus libertades
individuales han sido y seguirán siendo
efectivas mil a mí me llama la atención
que el doctor castillo está acá en
hopkins que han sido los pioneros en
enseñarlos día a día las estadísticas
donde lavan pero dos datos muy
importantes francia antes de comenzar el
país desarrollado con mayores anti bucks
es y sabíamos antes de comenzar las
vacunas que el 40% de la población decía
no me voy a vacunar y en que estamos
ahora 71 por ciento de cobertura y
subiendo de los eeuu totalmente
estancados japón muy difícil con las
vacunas con papiloma fue un completo es
comienzan en mayo en serio subiendo el
mismo canadá ya no queda país
desarrollado en el mundo con contadas
excepciones que éste con menor nivel que
a los eeuu que estuvo como decía eric
topol recientemente se como hemos
perdido esa oportunidad sí entonces digo
yo para estos países que tienen las
oportunidades y las vacunas los mandatos
son más digamos son más
directos de establecer que para algunos
países en quien no se ha vacunado es
porque la vacuna no le hay y el pueblo
está lejos no hay suficientes vacunas o
simplemente se acaban las segundas dosis
no pareciera que hay de todo ahí pero
los mandatos deben ser para quien está
en primera línea de atención doctor
torres continuó con usted aquí en el
estudio
rápidamente le pregunto algunas de las
dudas que surgen también en internet es
sobre lo convincente que puede ser este
nueva esta nueva generación de vacunas
que fue desarrollada para poder hacer
frente a esta este coronavirus del cubil
19 que es una nueva generación es algo
completamente nuevo no habíamos tenido
una vacuna anteriormente de este tipo
con el adn mensajero esto también genera
un poco de
incertidumbre no convence hay dudas
sobre la efectividad que luego hayan
tenido que salir a pedir una tercera
dosis porque la inmunización baja con el
paso de los meses no convence mucho a
las personas puede ser también haber
notado es más bien lo contrario
quiero aclarar que la plataforma de
reine a mensajero existe desde los 90s y
que básicamente estaba esperando una
enfermedad para poderlo hacer o sea ya
había vacunas en fase 1 fase 2 que se
habían probado pero las enfermedades o
habían pasado como el famoso sars de
comienzos del siglo 20 o simplemente tal
vez había unas vacunas más baratas más
disponibles y que funcionaban bien para
ponerse a hacer lo real esta tecnología
por la tecnología es segura no entra en
el sistema genético de las personas no
modifica el ácido nucleico y simplemente
llegó la condición y se tiene este
número de vacunas y se han puesto ya
miles de millones de dosis y más bien
estaremos leyendo en unos pocos años
historias épicas de la medicina de cómo
se ha hecho esto y de cómo se ha logrado
el efecto de estas vacunas ahora que no
vacuna requiere un refuerzo pues es lo
más normal de todo el mundo tus hijos
los hijos de los demás tienen cinco
dosis de vacunas de polio antes de los
cinco años se pone a los dos meses
cuatro meses seis meses luego otra y
luego otra aquí estamos peleando contra
un agresor
no conocemos bien cómo es su
comportamiento y por supuesto con
variantes nuevas probablemente
necesitamos refuerzos y de pronto no sea
el único pero eso es lo normal eso
simplemente nos está dando más confianza
sobre que se hace un seguimiento
científico adecuado de esta doctora
trejo en la ciudad de mexico él le
pregunto si no avanzamos en esta cruzada
contra el coronavirus si no logramos
vacunar a la mayor cantidad de personas
posible va a ser muy difícil superar
esta situación va a haber va a ser
posible llegar a una inmunidad vamos a
tener que convivir en las condiciones en
las que estamos en este momento
precisamente porque la vacunación no
pase de la situación en la que estamos
como lo ve usted
bueno en méxico con la variante delta
que ya es el 95 por ciento de la
circulación que tenemos en ciudad méxico
y en general todo el país
hoy lo que tenemos es como un aumento de
la transmisión importante no un aumento
de ocupación hospitalaria ni en gravedad
todos los datos que se arroja en estas
plataformas de nivel nacional no nos
arroja que estemos ante un tema de
gravedad y en relación a la cobertura de
vacunación tenemos una cobertura es de
primera dosis alta en relación a los
grupos que ya están incluidos no no a la
población completa sino a los grupos que
han ido avanzando el sistema de gobierno
y en segunda dosis pues tenemos una
cobertura más o menos del 37 por ciento
de ella con esquema completo sí sí ha
habido este estás retrasos en relación a
la vacunación aunque ha sido como muy
puntual el sistema si hay debates en
relación a vacunación no solamente la la
edad productiva sino también en los de
12 años en que es un tema importante en
nuestro país y creo yo que pues méxico
tiene que tomar las estrategias para
continuar con esta actividad económica y
por supuesto no dejar atrás pues todo
esto que dejamos atrás en la pandemia no
dejamos hacer las muchísimas cosas
muchísimos programas de salud que
también impactan pero la vacunación si
nos da mucha certidumbre en poder tomar
todos estos programas que antes teníamos
prioritarios no dejarlos fuera y creo yo
que al menos en méxico aunque la
vacunación inicio por ahí de diciembre
ha habido un avance importante en el
primer trimestre de este año después de
algo como un una disminución en relación
a la vacunación si hay esfuerzos
importantes para que la gente se vacuna
de sensibilización pero creo yo que
todavía no llegamos al punto este
después han sido desde esas medidas en
donde el gobierno tuviera que apoyar a
las empresas para que tomaran este tipo
de acciones como va a ser para niños de
otros países porque por supuesto las
empresas no saben qué hacer creo que nos
ha faltado hasta los programas para
empresas no de sistemas de salud sin
otro tipo de empresas que hacen
conseguir para las armen se está viendo
una deficiencia importante este al menos
en mi país y creo que de manera general
en todo el mundo a diferencia de países
de altos recursos económicos doctor
castillo un punto importante también
para analizar ya para ir cerrando que
vamos llegando al final del programa lo
decía el doctor estamos ante un enemigo
que estamos descubriendo sobre la marcha
lo estamos conociendo día a día y
también vemos que el coronavirus es muy
versátil hay muchas variantes y dentro
de las variantes muchas mutaciones y
muchos cambios va a ser fácil de poder
lograr una inmunidad con estas tasas de
vacunación que estamos presentando con
este virus tan fuerte tan versátil y
rápido para modificarse
desde luego cómo es posible que se tenga
que seguir la experiencia de influenza
que cada año se hacen los ajustes
necesarios dependiendo del tipo de
variantes que están circulando yo estoy
también de acuerdo que es importante
recordar que la inmunidad
que se da por la vacuna es superior a la
inmunidad natural ya que se da si la
persona ha sido infectada y estamos
perdiendo la perspectiva histórica por
ejemplo si usted quiere ir a viajar a
algún país donde existe hay problemas de
incremento de fiebre amarilla es
necesario y forzoso que usted tenga la
vacuna debía ver amarilla también
recordar que la historia la erradicación
total de la viruela fue debido a los
mandatos que exigieron que incluso con
la suprema corte de justicia de los
cause news que obligó la vacunación
masiva
contra la viruela y por tanto se logró
la
la erradicación de esta importante
enfermedad y yo pienso que el proceso de
vacunación es y el hecho de que los
científicos a nivel mundial son miles y
miles de científicos que están
trabajando
conjuntamente para lograr un seguimiento
de algo que antes la historia natural
por ejemplo de sida nos tomó 10 años la
historia natural de ccoo pit como 23
semanas y esto no creo que lo estamos
perdiendo en la perspectiva tenemos
miles y miles de profesionales que están
trabajando arduamente y no sólo con la
vacunación sino también con todo el
proceso de la respuesta a la salud
mental que tenemos que abordar muy
pronto y de otros elementos que son
fundamentales para mantener la calidad
de vida de las poblaciones a todos los
niveles y esos son factores que ha
gozado el mundo occidental en cierto
punto que ha gozado europa norteamérica
y parte de sudamérica pero todavía hay
buena parte del continente africano y
del sudeste asiático
a las vacunas 30 segundos para el cierre
me queda ya no alcanzo a hacer las
conclusiones pero les quiero agradecer a
los invitados por haber estado con
nosotros y por haber compartido con
nosotros sus opiniones y sus puntos de
vista la doctora rosa roxana trajo en la
ciudad de mexico carlos castillo en eeuu
y el doctor carlos torres aquí en el
estudio de france 24 gracias por haber
compartido sus puntos de vista y sus
impresiones sobre este tema y le
recuerdo ustedes pueden seguir dejando
sus comentarios y sus preguntas a través
de las redes sociales vacunación
obligatoria si o no analizamos los casos
de estados unidos y de francia muchas
gracias sigan con france 24
[Música]